hey I'm back we're going to talk about
the best way to consume eggs okay now
there's many different ways you can
consume X but here's the challenge when
you overcook the egg especially the egg
yolk it oxidizes the cholesterol okay it
forms a compound called oxys two rules
and what that does is it will tend to
create a platelet clump or a clogging of
the arteries okay so we want to avoid
that so based on this data and the next
piece of information i'm going to show
you what to do but if you have raw eggs
you actually decrease the protein
utilization and you you actually block
the absorption of biotin which is very
important in your hair and your nails
but primarily the hair because it's
involved with proteins so you want to
cook the white part and you can actually
keep the yolk runny okay so the best way
to cook eggs is to poach them fry them
and I do use butter or coconut oil I
make sure my yolks are running or likely
lightly scrambled okay that's not a
problem or boiled now when you boil them
the egg yolk is somewhat protected
because it's in the center so it really
it never really over oxidizes okay so
it's not going to be a problem so those
are the four methods of consuming eggs
alright thanks for watching